hello and welcome to insight Germany my
guest today is the astronomer Mary
Williams originally from New Zealand
Mary came here in 2007 to take up a post
at the light knits Institute for
Astrophysics which is in Potsdam welcome
to the show you came here to work at the
light knits institute named after the
famous mathematician and philosopher and
I think I know what astronomy is but I'm
not sure I know what astrophysics is
what's that what's that
well well astronomy is the study of
observing the heavens we in astrophysics
we try to take those observations and
understanding the underlying physics
underneath it all and do you go into the
past then with with looking into the
exact time we look at the Stars we're
looking at the past cuz it takes a bit
of time for this for the light to get to
us you see and the further away things
are the more in the past that you're
looking okay and I said that because you
one of the things you discovered and got
a prize for was you found a galaxy that
have been swallowed up by our galaxy now
we won't go into that quite yeah that's
quite common but basically what's a
galaxy okay so a galaxy is a collection
of dark matter stars gas and dust
now our galaxy is called the Milky Way
and it's a collection of about a hundred
billion stars a hundred billion yes each
one well different different sizes
shapes sizes compete to our Sun so our
Sun is a star let's not forget that as
well just grounded and the basics and
how many galaxies are there without
number oh I see well there's billions
and billions and billions and billions
millions billions of galaxies are Kyle
actually there's billions of stars so
it's pretty big it's pretty big we're
all pretty insignificant so now why did
you come to to Germany to do - to work
in astronomy then well because I did my
PhD in Australia at not strong
Observatory and what was involved if a
project could rave there which stands
for radial velocity experiment and rave
is an international collaboration but
the two main Institute's are in
Australia as where it's observed this
does the observations are May and in
Germany it's led by the the the leader
of the Institute Mattia time it's so
that's that's why I came here another
reason I assist your Observatory in a in
Australia was in the middle of nowhere
and presume you can see the stars better
yes
and yet you're in possum which is just
outside Berlin there's lots of
disturbing light when you're looking
through the I was just saying the other
night there's a bit said that I come all
this way to study the Stars and yet I
can't really see them here anymore
because the light pollution is so much
that you really well you can just if you
just go out into the countryside you can
see the stars a lot clearer you can't
see the Milky Way but I mean this other
stars are but more interesting in my
opinion because you've got the imaginary
clouds and things like that so the
Magellanic Clouds are these two little
galaxies are flying by our own galaxy
and they you can see them just with the
naked eye in the southern hemisphere
well in the northern hemisphere been
from I was going to say this is in the
southern hemisphere isn't it I should
let's show our first picture you sent me
this picture there's a beautiful picture
of the countryside in New Zealand it's
right and I believe this is where your
interest in astronomy started that's
right yes right so a friend of the
families owned a farm about two hours
south of Auckland and Raglan and this is
a picture from the farm and we used to
go there every holiday when I was a
child and and the the the night sky at
the farm was brilliant it was so so full
of stars they actually I couldn't see
the constellations actually had to come
back to the city to make up the
constellations because there were so
many stars that the constellations got
kind of you know obscured by the number
of stars that were there they were so
like you know big fit Muffy stars like
you know they feel really they're really
really fast got you going because I mean
I've seen I've seen the stars from the
desert and I was amazed I must admit it
is completely different from sitting in
a city you know but it didn't start me
off to be in a strong
did what sort of was the connection you
saw these beautiful but then did you
then did you start into being interested
in the mathematics of it or a while I've
always been interested in mathematics
and science and chemistry physics those
were always my sort of thing and I guess
with astronomy I really I mean I was
kind of enchanted by the beauty of it
all but also because of the grand scale
of things I already like big things you
know galaxies mountains that sort of
thing so you know the scale of things
really enchanted me and this Germany a
leader in this field absolutely Germany
Germany has a lot of Institute's I mean
you've got the Max Planck Institute's
and yeah this is a very always well
represented it must have been quite
daunting though coming here in 2007
because I haven't I dunno you didn't
speak a word of the language did you
yeah I'd spend a couple of months living
in the Netherlands
during my PhD and I kind of thought it
would be like that it was nothing yeah I
say that also because you're now I know
you're about to go on a course in
Germany you're gonna take exams because
you in your questionnaire that we sent
to all I guess you're the first guest
who's come back to us and said that
after the initial sort of fear of the
language you find it very beautiful now
German isn't often called beautiful yeah
well I think if you just get past the
you know what people think is a guttural
side of it I don't it can't be just
tuned it out you know and I think there
I don't know it's got a beautiful
cadence to it if you ask me and yeah I
think it's I think it's a beautiful
language I do yeah I mean it is the
language of goethe and schiller and of
course great composers wrote music that
way anyway let's find out right now
more about Mary Williams specific area
of work and the place where she works
that's the light knits Institute for
Astrophysics just outside the city of
Berlin in the city of pasta
we can't go to the stars you know play
around with them do experiments with
them like we can in other fields what we
see is what we get it was great working
in a place which has our history I mean
we are I should I would have been around
as well these beautiful buildings here
with the historical telescopes what I'm
interested in is how galaxies form and
involve studying this process in the
Milky Way itself our Milky Way is this
interesting for humans in general
because it's our galaxy I work on an
international collaboration of about 50
researchers from around the world we're
doing a survey of stars in the Milky Way
we require spectra of the stars and this
is time-consuming by using fiber optics
bit regards we're able to do a lot of
stars at once galaxies formed fire and
hierarchical process where little
galaxies merged together to form larger
galaxies and what I'm interested in is
to look for remnants of these formation
events I discovered a little galaxies
that have been eaten by our own galaxy
the realization of a small dream I had
took two years to understand what I was
seeing
I mean you look at what people under
sort of the universe a hundred years ago
and what we understand now we really are
in a golden age and this John I mean the
2011 Nobel Prize mates to astronomy this
was very exciting for all of us doesn't
happen so often no no prizes aren't so
important to me I'm much more of a
curiosity person I'm happiest when I'm
just working on a problem trying to
figure it out you know we all trying to
understand our place in the universe and
trying to understand why are we here and
by studying astronomy I'm contributing
to that knowledge
do you think you understand your place
in the universe better than most of us
by studying astronomy well I think I
know how insignificant I am and how
wonderful it is to exist because I mean
it's so unlikely that you exist of all
these billions and billions of galaxies
each of billions of stars I mean how
wonderful it is that we're here yeah and
I know it says in that report it took
you two years to find out that this
galaxy was swallowed by our galaxy the
Milky Way but can you tell us how you
found that out in sort of half a minute
no I mean how do you find out those sort
of things okay so we were observing
stars okay so this rate survey we took
and the light from the stars and by
using this light we were able to tell
how fast the stars are going towards or
away from us and and I was able to find
a group of stars that shouldn't have
been there basically we have our moles
of the galaxy and we know how the
velocities the speed should be and there
was an over density group of stars each
that shouldn't have been there and
looking at that and doing some models
and comparing that to the models were
able to establish that it was probably
from our stream of stars that was likely
from a galaxy of remnant that was eaten
now this is part of the way galaxies
form like little galaxies all come
together and form a bigger galaxy and
this is an ongoing process so there's
lots of different galaxies being you
know shredded or had been shredded by
the Milky Way what's special about this
street the stream is it's really close
to us and it's right in the disk it's
really well really know your writing or
have you started writing your book for
children on astronomy yeah well yeah I
want to explain basically our place in
the universe that's my idea just I want
to book that so I'm picks up and an
adult and a child within 10 minutes they
understand things because a lot of the
children's stuff on astronomy only stops
at the solar system and the solar system
is only the beginning really do you
think you can I mean I'm understanding
what you're saying today
because I'm a child when it comes to
astronomy so do you do you think you can
do this explain it further for there
okay okay so we'll start with the solar
system because everyone's familiar with
it we've got the Sun at the center big
boy guess and got the the earth as a
third Rock from the Sun and then there's
you know this is a tennis yeah and
there's this you know is about eight
planets because we chose been demoted we
won't talk about there and then boot oh
yeah poor Pluto okay and then so the
nearest star is four light-years away
now we want to make this very clear that
our Sun is a star because I mean I
didn't realize this in twelves and it's
embarrassingly late agent was about
eleven years old or something like that
and I wanted to be an astronomer just
for embarrassed I'm sixty and I've just
realized well just like I mean it's just
like the sort of stuff just doesn't get
told to people when it's just so easy
something that everyone can understand
you know and and so we're in the Milky
Way galaxy it's a spiral galaxy I think
even we've seen a picture of a spiral
galaxy now the report okay we're not at
the center everyone thinks we're at the
scene - the galaxy we're not at the
centre about three-quarters of the way
out on the edge of a spiral arm very
small spiral arm not not very important
you're beginning to make us more and
more insignificant and in so there's
another big boy in the in the Local
Group of galaxies that's the Andromeda
well it's a no spiral one there's other
little galaxies around and all galaxies
are arrayed on a kind of filamentary
bubble structure so there's big voids
where there's nothing and there's it's
filaments where the galaxies all
everything's condensing along those
those ranges I think we better stick
we'd better come back to Terra Firma now
we'll go to the other side of the world
because we've got a map of where you're
from New Zealand which is really is the
other side of the world and from
Auckland is that is that the North or
the South eyes sorry okay and you'd left
I mean you've you were there till just
2007 you were there no no I lived in
2003 I went to Australia for five years
mm-hmm and I've got a photo here I want
to show of my favorite photo that you
sent him this you put this is a
I believe your family and you said off
to a wedding underneath I wonder if we
can see that can you desert
first of all tell us which what are you
I'm the little curly-haired one with the
dolly in her hands in the middle in the
middle yeah that's right under you
really off to a wedding I think my
parents were my we weren't we're not
dressed up but my parents were all still
willing and yeah that's I think what
happened my father looks like he's from
1945 in that photo and we stopped
smoking soon afterwards I think and
we'll move on to another photo oh that's
it that is I believe your favorite place
yes right let's Rob for Iglesia try next
to one occur in the South Island and we
meet there this year so I've been there
a few times
I mean Thea this year and yeah this is
so beautiful you got through this beech
forest and you get up to a high alpine
meadow meadow and is glacier with about
20 waterfalls coming off it and these
mountain parrots called Kia's come up
and try and steal your food it's lovely
Wow and it as we mentioned earlier it
was pretty daunting arriving here but
what has changed all that because I
think we can reveal now you've become a
month in you've been here six years in
that time you've not only discovered
amazing things in astronomy but you've
become a mother and you have a little
baby Lily who's now a year old so you
start the families this is a from
arriving quite daunted you've settled
here that's right so I met my partner in
Australia doing and we did a PhD PhD
there and since German he's German yeah
and he he he just happened to move to
Munich and we were friends at the stage
and then we um we got together finally I
think everyone was like all finally you
guys got together so I was sure it
should have happened years ago and then
yeah so we've been going out since about
2008 and and then he moved over to he
actually gave up astronomy so that we
could be together and moved here a
couple of years ago because we were
doing a long-distance thing for three
years or so and it was you know it's a
lot of academics to do that sort of
thing yeah
I'll ask you Munich but I again another
photo that the cutest photo that you've
sent to us because this is of your baby
on the Left I think it's right it's Lily
Lily looking at Miranda and Miranda is
was also a great help while Miranda has
some net but perhaps her mother it was a
great help when you were here yes right
so my cousin happened it's a long story
that about why my cousin came here she
came to visit and I said well you know
do you want to come over and live then
do and so six months later she packed up
everything in New Zealand and move over
to Germany and so we lived together for
the first couple of years I was here in
Berlin and here in Berlin and Shina Berg
yeah that's right and then such now she
has a German partner and I have a German
partner and we had babies within two and
a half months of each other and so yeah
so lily and Miranda were fighting
yesterday
Berlin's becoming a I mean there's lots
and lots of people from outside Germany
moving here I mean we we don't have
trouble getting guests on our show
that's right it's a great place to come
to his work one thing you know very
comfortable living you know you have
really good social support here very
good financial support yeah I wanted to
ask about that as a young mother I mean
did you find the support here good that
before you had the baby after you've had
the baby well there's a lot of financial
support by the government here so I mean
pretty much unheard off and a lot of
unkind other countries you get a year
off at 65% of your pay and and then that
you actually get periods of two months
after the birth and six weeks before at
full pay so you get you get a lot of
support and it's um yeah and actually
you can get extra time and that
financial support if the father takes
time off as well so that's that's we did
that that's when we went to New Zealand
this year yeah and what about the apart
from the financial support it is your I
don't want to but I mean yeah about
other support the caring support leading
up to the birth and well you did a very
good out of a fantastic Midwife and and
you know it's been really great you know
I think I haven't met the other side yet
which is when you go back
to work I hear that there are a bit more
problems when you are back at work
because it's a bit harder to combine
family life and in in your work life
because I mean they kind of expect it to
be the the mother on the mummy Trek
thing and I think in Germany I've heard
of this but in my Institute is quite
happy for me to go back part time and
the next in the near future so I haven't
actually a personal experience of that
yet myself but social you know I found
it very great I mean I mean I have to
say that I mean I'm in the expect
community here as well so we have you
know english-speaking cafes where we can
go and talk in English with what you do
do English activities with our children
which is important because we shouldn't
be speaking in German that's kind of you
know I'd be teaching Lily an incorrect
German if I spoke to her in German yeah
I mean but you're a bilingual family are
you bringing her up you're intending to
I mean she's she's nearly I think she's
nearly 1 there's really sort of fluent
in both languages yet but is that in the
intention it's right that's right yes so
she's learning probably more English at
the moment because she's with me a lot
other time hmm you know she can say
things like squish talking about squish
we just quickly go back to astronomy
because just recently breaking news in
fact really evidently our galaxy wobbles
or and you said to me on the telephone
when we spoke the other day it's squishy
yeah what walls wasn't probably the
right team to use it sounded better on
them yeah actually being squishy well
okay so so we was rotating right but
what we discovered with a special class
of rave starts or there's back to the
rave observations I was talking about
earlier is that the the the motion of
the galaxy isn't quite it's you know
smooth as we thought it was there's a
lot of up-and-down motion going on and
things like think of like a wobbly jelly
can I going you know squishing in and
out it's not a rather large scale it's a
large scale very large scale I'm talking
about the disco and it just is very
unexpected
so that that was that was what we we
found in the latest paper back to Terra
Ferber once again sorry just when you
said the word squishy it made me think
the thing I'd read the other day what
we'd spoke them out now as I said back
to Terra Firma your favorite place in
Germany is a place called Saxon
Switzerland do you actually know why
it's called sex no in Saxon Switzerland
I was hoping it's called in German
there's extra spice but which is
translated Saxon switzer the way it
looks I think it looks yeah it's it's
beautiful it's absolutely gorgeous I
mean it's probably the most mountainous
part that you can get in the
neighbourhood of Berlin which it's quite
important for us and we go to visit the
best I rocks every year so it's old
castle that well fortress it was there
and we like to go an autumn and because
of the autumnal colors this is gorgeous
and you have to catch a ferry to get
across there which is always a bit
stressful when you're trying to get the
train back Harry yeah sorry where I
thought I knew where it was it's not an
island is it all of you know 50 metres
across but they have no I don't allowed
to build a bridge because the ferry
operators go back and forth back and
forth all day and it's because a bit
stressful trying to get to the catch the
train back but in general it's a
beautiful day trip and it's always very
busy with people coming from Berlin and
yeah really nice hiking you know we're
intrigued I think our audience is
intrigued let's have a look at Mary's
favorite bit of countryside here in
Germany it is I have to say a very
unique part of the country the sandstone
that is the foundation of Dresden's
architectural beauty is a gift of nature
boats once transported the building
material into the city and today boats
carry visitors to the source of the
sandstone the Romantics called the
region Saxon Switzerland and used the
landscape as a frequent motif in their
work towering 200 metres over the river
is one of the best-known landmarks in
Saxon Switzerland the bust eye bridge it
was specially built for visitors at the
neue hotend fortress in 1826
it's the views that make the Elbe
sandstone mountains so special in a
Cretaceous period the region was covered
in water
rough quartz sand clay and fine marl
sank and solidified layer by layer
developing over the millennia into the
craggy landscape that we see here today
the Elbe sandstone mountains are popular
with climbers but they have to adhere to
the rules to protect the rock climbers
may only secure their ropes at official
fixed points but the over 1000
freestanding Peaks will delight the
heart of any aficionado of the sport
thanks to the National Park status
peregrine falcons have been able to
settle here the area measuring 200
square kilometers provides a tranquil
natural habitat undisturbed even by the
many official tourist trails
there's much to discover on these
far-flung hiking trails the Malevich or
painters way takes in some of the most
romantic corners of the park
Sunstone is easy to work with a quality
much appreciated by sculptors and
restores
not only Dresden but the town of Pune
boasts examples of traditional stone
masonry attesting to its history as a
flourishing trade center
the Saxon Switzerland region is one of
amazing natural beauty and my guest is
Mary Williams the astronomer and it's
your favorite place is it any does it
remind you at all of New Zealand perhaps
I don't know bit more over some parts in
Australia where we do the observations
has a bit more that kind of yeah it just
doesn't to me look like Germany yeah no
you're right it's kind of a bit of out
of the box really isn't it yeah yeah
that's that's why it's called sexy yeah
doesn't really look like Switzerland but
now you're a fan of the mountains and
hiking I know but did you have you ever
climbed those rocks do you know I used
to do some rock climbing but not for
many years I'm much more of a Heike type
of person this chance of death you know
and you mentioned about being in Munich
going back and forth for three years
because of your your fella and then and
you this is a picture I think of yeah
not Munich that was when we did our an
Alpine Traverse coming down from I think
we're coming down from Switzerland into
Italy and yeah we did I think it was
about four or five day Traverse there it
was really lovely yeah yeah
do you use back that one I think I was
quite happy then because we're over the
snow fields you know so and I'm like
walking on the snow kills bit yeah bit
trickier and Munich obviously you're
going back involved Munich's much nearer
to the outs much nearer so that that
sort of countryside you that you love so
but you wouldn't settle there well um
well at the moment my family is in
Berlin don't forget I've got my cousin
here and her family and it's a great
international community in Berlin we
have toyed with the idea of meaning
moving to Munich because it is near in
the mountains and it is a lot easy to
get down to other parts of of Europe but
it's just
yeah we're sealed here for the moment
yes the only thing is is that Berlin I
think the winters might drive me out
there there they're pretty harsh in
Berlin you know we have four or five
months and everything shuts down but
they're pretty harsh in Munich aren't
they though it's somehow somehow you
know not quite so
so you know it's not quite as far north
I think you know it's the thing you
don't get the black ice that lasts for
two months and in Berlin that I find
quite difficult and do you find for
expats as well meaning is I I think it's
got quite strong expect community as
well but I think Berlin is probably a
bit more international and I think
that's quite important for me at this
point of time because I'm trying to
raise Lili bilingually so that's kind of
you know when you have to have that side
as well yeah but on a day like today
when it's all there's lots of fog and
mist around today you could certainly
can't look at the skies or can you
actually with these powerful telescope
well you know not not in the visible
range now you can know yeah
but we don't think there's much
observation stand in the way around
Berlin these days so yeah and anyway
you're a full-time mum at the moment I
want to come on to a couple of things
from the questionnaire you said you love
Munich the Alps but Berlin is great for
expats we've had that but your favorite
German word I was quite interested
two of them first one tour it's pretty
weird it's beautiful why I should say it
means gate it's right in German actually
in English I'm thinking of the
Glastonbury Tor at the tour is the top
of a mountain to search the mountain
reference again isn't it yeah I guess
maybe yeah I just got a beautiful sound
to it oh I see yeah I should just
mention in case people think I don't
know that tour also in Germany is what
you hear a lot when Germany plays
England at football because they always
should I be say this is an Englishman
but and the word for goal in German is
perhaps our audience did as well the
other words you registered is your
favorite show word cheeky Mickey yeah
the first time I heard that word it was
in referring to Munich and they didn't
have to explain what it means well I
understood it means posh or you know
that sort of thing I think I think do
you think she keep it I don't know
actually whether it's orig
a German word I think it's very
onomatopoeia really yes Mickey yeah but
do you think that the the the Bavarians
are more they're definitely more should
be Mickey then I think it's a Lewin
turned the lintel very down-to-earth
that's why I like about Berlin that's
very true
that's very true and I think that maybe
the big difference now your favorite
German film and a number of our guests
have put this on my set but you have it
make me laugh well I'd go too
embarrassed you know you your favorite
German film is dust bought mm-hmm and
you did think it was something else
before he went said yeah well spelled be
OoT yeah I was watching it was a German
flatmate in Australia gave it to me to
watch and I was watching last two hours
and and I constructed this whole theory
about why it was called the boot I
thought you know they're going to Italy
it's shaped like a boot and I just
remember the moment we she explained to
me to me
the boat surely you're two hours into
this thing which took place in the
submarine yes well it's a submarine it's
all about gentlemen this is one of the
world's top astronomers so we'll move on
trade free Sundays I know you like those
and that's something I'm with you there
by the way completely I I think it's
wonderful yeah I think that when I first
arrived it stressed me out completely
because you know come Saturday afternoon
you'd be like food I need food for
tomorrow otherwise I'm going to starve
you know and so you'd go out and forage
for food very rapidly but now you know
it really punctuates a week you have a
space where is no commercialism you know
and I think that's very important I mean
I think I heard you saying earlier about
how England is very commercialized
everything's very capitalistic there and
I think in Germany by having this you
have this pause where everyone steps
back a little bit and has a space for
the family or friends you know and and
it has actually some time to rest about
having to go out and shop you know and I
think that's that's really important it
has some day somehow that
the shops are closed on Sundays
around Christmastime they do have
special concessions but it has a
different dynamic somehow isn't it you
see people walking in the park I mean no
not rushing along the streets of the
next shop yo you is going to do your
cafe you know coffee and cake on it and
on a Sunday afternoon after a walk you
know you which you earn by walking and
so it's kind of a nice little in part of
the week I look forward to it yeah and
you put down an interesting one for
great culinary achievement here because
you put their beer yes I like I like the
German beer I can't drink too much of it
at the moment but because of the little
lady but yeah but they have a very good
alcohol free beers here though as well
and yeah my favorite addition iDevice
beer oh it's lovely
I believe we weren't introduced to
German beer in Germany no it was in New
Zealand I had a Bavarian master
supervisor and he took us along to a
beer house and set me down and so now
you're going to taste the best thing in
the world and indeed it was and I should
say you said Schneider Weiser this is a
veidt's and beer yeah this is a wheat
beer my favourite that originally wasn't
part they have a very famous thing here
the Reinheitsgebot the German beer
Purity door it wasn't within it because
you had to have water hops and barley
and it's been sort of loosened over the
years but and and now this veidt's and
beer this wheat beer I've noticed it's
on sale in England you obviously had it
in New Zealand it's obviously round the
world that's right you know it was ten
times the price and New Zealand than
what it is in Germany because it's a go
all that way you know okay anyway this
country is of course famous for its beer
and it's breweries there are over 1300
breweries and more than 5000 types of
beer in Germany so Mary's got a lot of
time to try them out when she can have a
have a drink again not many people know
that it was women who brewed the beer
actually back in the Middle Ages and
today they're making something of a
comeback a common image of beer is of
men raising mugs of the frothy brew and
to those who say there's nothing less
ladylike than beer well times are
changing
talika strata of debt mod is living
proof that babes can brew two together
with her sister Sylvia she's part of a
team that runs a thriving brewery
Frederika is the fifth generation of her
family to brew a small traditional
business employs only 30 people it
doesn't advertise traditionally the beer
was made for regional consumption until
recently now it's in demand across
Germany an online beer tastes his club
crown the to snail de brew their beer of
the year
today men dominate the brewing industry
but that didn't used to be the case at
all in medieval times brewing was
traditionally a woman's job only the
monks in their monasteries competed with
a female made ales bureau and thrown
beer and women always went together
because the women had to take care of
food and drink beer was included even in
ancient Egypt the Babylonians and the
Titans it was the same mass production
of beer only began with the onset of
industrialization when men took over
but today singular flavorful beers are
back in demand and that's exactly what
Esther Isaac has on sale at Hamburg a
pile and the inventory includes 300
types from all over the world people
call the former interpreter of a beer
queen because she knows just the right
beer for every drinker
phones and even women come here looking
for a special taste experience a gourmet
experience men are simply thirsty that's
why men aren't really welcome when
Bali's angels meet it's a 5000 member
club for female connoisseurs of brew
worldwide esta Isaac founded a German
branch last year every trace of taste
counts beer is an unexplored universe in
its own right I've always liked drinking
here but this isn't a typical Becks or
whatever I don't like those then I came
here and this was a little paradise it's
a great idea as a woman you've got so
many drinks to choose from and sometimes
you're uncertain about trying beer
called civilized how much mannish and
beyond
Bali's Angels is a growing phenomenon in
Germany and elsewhere in the world a
growing group of ladies who want to have
their say about brews to savor my guest
likes beer it's Mary Williams the
astronomer do you think we both laugh
then when we heard to them the women
like the taste men are thirsty yes I
think that's true now we're coming to
the last few minutes that I've got one
more embarrassing photo for you if it'll
what had to be that one didn't you sent
it yeah that's from a party in Australia
the Priscilla Queen of the desert party
we had a lot of fun down there doing
these sorts of things and that was for
my student life which is a very
different life to what I lead now I have
to say I'm sure but that's what I wanted
to point out that the lady on the right
if there's my friend Ainsley or my
effect that is a dress made up of of
gendell's or anyt flop flip stops these
you know we call them candles I mean if
if the audience looks closely it took me
a time but I thought what is she wearing
you know which it's actually a dress
made up of flip-flops yeah it's from
Priscilla Queen of the desert the movie
and
yeah oh I see now you you say again I
refer back to the questionnaire a couple
more things you say good German
characteristic you put down they have a
strong sense of fairness and social
justice yeah I agree with it I think
that in Germany you know I don't I don't
feel this in other countries where you
kind of lift your own devices with
regards to I mean there's a good social
support and financial support for
starters and yeah I don't know
they are very fear kind people in
general although I think that sometimes
they they can veer a little bit too much
unto thee you know everything has to be
done a certain way side and this is for
yourself of the irritating Germans it's
the same kind of thing and you mentioned
there a story of the sock police yeah
that's right so the last summer you know
we it was very warm it's a very warm
summer it's very warm in Berlin and so I
don't feel that it's necessary for a
baby to always have socks on their feet
if they're out in public because they
don't like to wear them you know they
take them off at the first opportunity
and so if you're out and about with your
child and a pram it doesn't have socks
on people come up to you and ask you
we're their socks I wear their shoes and
this happens on a daily basis you know
and in any and you know ask for
parenting advices is always irritating
so and yeah we call it the sock police
like oh I got a sock police today and
you know it's just kind of commiserate
amongst ourselves one it kind of comes
with the other does that yeah I think so
you have to conform everything you know
you know you mentioned also public
transport in the big cities that it's so
wonderful but you complain here in
Berlin about the s-bahn which is the
overground trains yeah I say it's very
underman I don't understand it there and
it's a bit of a mystery why this phone
doesn't work very well in Berlin I'll
say this I think you've been here too
long I think you have to go possible I
don't about New Zealand but I've just
been to London so we hear the s-bahn
here I'm just looking into the camera
and telling every
the s-bahn here don't believe her the
sbox works fine it occasionally breaks
down but compared to most other
countries don't you think the public
okay all right I probably get quite
irritated when I have to wait for 10
minutes when there's there's no train
let's we've got just a minute left
you said it's a Golden Age of astronomy
why is that why is it well we can do so
many observations these days it's
wonderful telescopes and satellites that
we're able to see so much more than we
ever could before and with the computing
power understand what we're seeing it's
it's this and there's so many
astronomers working these days as well I
mean that's what do you think it's gonna
be the next big thing in astronomy
possibly very quickly now you put me on
the spot I work because you see dark
matter dark matter dark energy
what what matter dark matter and dark
energy what it what is that we don't
know I think that's like the next big
thing you know that's the next thing to
crack so you know what was these things
that make up the equations all that we
can see is there but we don't know what
it is you know we know it's there
because because of the way it's
influencing things but we don't know
what it is Barry Williams thank you very
much you heard it here first dark matter
and dark energy look out for that and if
you'd like to writers if you'd like to
pose a question to Mary write to us at
insight at DWD a question about
astronomy a question about living in
Germany or you can write to us as well
about anything you like please do thanks
to my guest Mary Williams and thank you
for watching and we'll see you hopefully
at the same time next week or the next
time you put on your computer and watch
it wherever fun hat
you